uh exciting things have been happening
in our solar system there have been
reports recently of a a dark spot a
bruise that as they've been calling it
on the planet jupiter and this was
actually discovered by an amateur
astronomer in australia there are spots
all over this is the other thing that's
going on because there was a spot also
discovered on venus this is a white spot
rather than a black spot um and
astronomers are still arguing about what
might have caused it it's actually very
bright it's in sort of a
[Music]
fairly low southern latitudes in venus
so again was discovered by an amateur
astronomer just taking some pictures of
venus around suddenly this big white
spotted appeared um anything sort of
changing in astronomy is sort of unusual
most of the things we look at in
astronomy you know stars galaxies and so
on they just sit there unchanging for
billions of years so it's always
interesting when something new does
appear
so it's pretty exciting news he sent
reports out to
a few nasa outlets and just kind of the
blogosphere in general and it started to
be picked up and then some of the major
telescopes in hawaii and the hubble
space telescope took images of it in the
near infrared and an optical and new
spots come and go reasonably regularly
on jupiter so just having something new
appear on jupiter isn't that unusual
what's unusual about this is that it's a
black spot and as far as we know the
only thing that can make black spots or
something actually smacking into the
planet and so what they think is that
this actually is um the result of an
impactor like an asteroid or a comet
that hit jupiter similar to the one that
happened almost exactly 15 years ago
which was comet shoemaker levy so we
actually watched that one break up in
pieces and slam into jupiter and the
result was at each point where a piece
slammed into the atmosphere of jupiter
we could see these really dark spots
resulting from that what's a little
surprising about this one is that no one
was expecting it you know the in the
case of this comment the comment had
been tracked for months and months
beforehand and it was all very well
predicted and people were watching it
and expecting it to happen um and this
was just a completely unexpected event
and judging from the size of the of the
dent it's made the size of this black
spot that is created in the clouds uh it
was quite a big object that smacked into
it probably a kilometer or so in size so
it's really quite a sizable event
smashing into into jupiter's surface
it's i mean is it you know there's a bad
side on the good side the bad side is it
means there are lots of things out there
of that kind of size just whizzing
around the solar system that we don't
know about and in principle one of them
could smash into the earth
and that's you know that really is kind
of you know dinosaur wiping out kind of
size of objects pretty serious from that
point of view
the interesting thing is that one of the
things that astronomers have found doing
calculations looking at the structure of
the solar system and modeling the
movements of these these asteroids these
small bodies is that actually jupiter to
an extent protects us from them that
when things come flying in from the
outer solar system um jupiter they
either smash into jupiter or jupiter
sort of deflects them away and so
jupiter acts as something of a shield
protecting us and so it could be in fact
this object smashing into jupiter was an
example of jupiter acting in this sort
of protectoral role of actually stopping
things from getting into the solar
system in a solar system
and potentially doing bad things to the
earth the other big thing in the solar
system happened on venus so actually on
the same day
news sources were reporting that there
was a bright spot that occurred on venus
and these it just looks like a really
bright white kind of elongated structure
now
such white features have been seen in
the clouds of venus before
but this is far bigger than any other
that has been detected before we're not
entirely sure
astronomers don't really know how it was
created so it's possible one theory is
that there was a volcano on the surface
that sent up a lot of
material into the upper atmosphere so if
that sulfur dioxide there's a lot of
that and venus reacted with the water
vapor and the upper atmosphere then it
can form sulfuric acid things like that
which become really reflective of the
sun's light so it just increases its
brightness and we can identify it that
way
that one again it was another amateur
astronomer who discovered it and then um
reported it to various news sources and
and astronomy organizations oh we get
very excited so with the because i mean
by the wonders of the internet basically
as soon as these things are discovered
the entire world knows about them um and
so as soon as we learn about them we can
actually go out there and follow up with
the much bigger telescopes and get much
more detailed
more detailed pictures of them and so
for example there's a new camera just
being installed on the hubble space
telescope which isn't actually even
commissioned yet it's not even actually
supposed to be doing taking data yet but
as when this event came up they got so
excited about it that they actually went
and took some pictures with it and took
of the the big black spot on jupiter the
new black spot on jupiter and we're able
to kind of get some very high quality
pictures of it it's good that
professional astronomers have big
telescopes that can look out to very
specific places but it's also really
nice to have a lot of smaller telescopes
smaller eyes
looking at various places as often as
they can
for discoveries like this for work like
this the stuff that amateur astronomers
do is absolutely invariant valuable just
because there is just so much out there
in space and there's only maybe what ten
thousand professional astronomers in the
world so there's no way we can be
looking at it all i'm glad that it's a
science where not only professional
people but also amateurs can contribute
as well because
they're contributing great things to our
general knowledge which is ultimately
what we want whether or not you do it as
a job or a hobby let's figure out how
the universe works